(electronic music)
(laughter)
- I was like living with
this older single man
and it gets sad
around the house,
sometimes, we're just
two lonely hearts
haunting the same hallway,
we barely talk to each other,
just passing in the night.
And it gets sad, the other day,
I recently caught
him making pancakes
for himself, that's
not a single man food.
(laughter)
That's for your family.
That's for your
beautiful wife Jeannine
and your fuckin' boys just
won a hockey championship.
You getting around,
slice up strawberries,
you have a nice time.
Just one lonely man
looking out the window
like that's pretty fluffy.
(laughter)
That tastes better than the gun
I was gonna put in my mouth.
(laughter)
Well, it's been a lot
of fun, thank you.
(cheering and applause)
- [Presenter] Casey
James Salengo.
(upbeat music)
(bell)
- Hey, how you doin'?
I'm gonna take a turkey,
cheddar, lettuce,
tomato, pickles,
mayo and mustard on a hard
roll please, thank you.
Is that a hard roll?
Is that the...
turkey, cheddar,
tomato, lettuce,
mayonnaise and mustard.
And pickles if you got 'em.
- Ten bucks, please.
- There's a 20,
and okay.
Not gonna eat that.
Hey, how you doin', sir?
Can I get two steak
tacos, extra sour cream,
and that'll do it, thank you.
- [Presenter] We're so
thrilled to have him here.
- [Other Presenter]
Oh, brother bear.
- [Presenter] Ladies
and gentlemen,
- [Presenters] Ryan Beck
- You always hear
this from older guys,
they go "oh college, that's
the best time in your life."
I was trying to figure out
why older guys always tell you
that college is the
best time in your life
and I think it's because
college is the only time
in your life as a
man when the women
are attracted to potential.
(laughter)
After that, they're
very results-oriented.
My favorite class
that I took in college
was a black studies course
for the whole dynamic
of the class was just like
me and one other white dude
in an auditorium
full of black people
and then one day as
part of the class,
we got tested on all of
the racial stereotypes
for black people
throughout all of history
and they handed out the test
and I started to fill it out
and I realized "oh, I
should not be the first one
"to turn this in."
(laughter)
I'm trying to make eyes to
the other white guy in class,
like "no, you go first."
- Hey, man.
- Hey, dude, what's goin' on?
- Not much, how's your night?
- Pretty good, headed
to a gig, how about you?
- My night fucking sucks bro.
- What's wrong?
- Nobody will fuck me, man.
- Don't say that
dude, someone will.
- I mean what do I have to do?
You look at me, what
do I have to do?
I'm out here every
day, trying my hardest
and then all the girls
fuck all these gross guys.
- Been there, brother,
I don't know what
to tell you, sorry.
- You've been there, a
nice tall guy like you?
- Hey, it even happens to me.
- I bet you never jerk off.
- I-
- I got to sit at home
and I got to jerk
off every night.
I'm 35 year old and I jerk
off all over the goddamn room.
- All over the room, huh?
- I've jerked off every
day for three years,
just sit in my room,
jerking my dick.
- Wow that's tough.
- What do I got to do, man?
Tell me what I gotta do,
please, please, please,
just tell me anything, man-
- Can I just... you want advice?
- Yes.
- Listen, you're
a very nice guy-
- I know.
- You're very friendly.
- You've got a lot of
positive qualities,
but there's one thing,
you're covered in rice, dude
and I feel like that's
a big part of it.
- Fuck you, man.
- Why though?
- You think that I don't know
that I'm covered in rice?
Everybody tells me that
I'm covered in rice.
I'm a messy eater.
- You know that you're
covered in rice?
- I love rice.
That doesn't mean that
I don't deserve love
just because I like to eat.
- All right, man, well
you'll figure it out-
- I love rice, I have
to be at my mom's house,
jerking off for
the rest of my life
because I can't eat right?
- It's just too much rice.
- Fuck you!
(subway horn)
(cheering)
- We adopted a dog
which has been...
She's so sweet, I love this dog.
We rescued the dog,
that's what you gotta do,
you gotta rescue the dogs
because it is cheaper.
(laughter)
Just so much cheaper,
$75 for my best friend.
You give the city 75 bucks
and then all you gotta
do is check a box
that says that you won't use
the dog as a food source.
(laughter)
That's it, that's
all you gotta do.
I was like look, if
we were gonna eat her,
we would've got a bigger one.
(laughter)
(upbeat music)
- [Presenter] Everybody,
you're gonna love this guy.
Put your hands together
for Casey James Salengo.
(applause)
- Thank you boys, how you doin'?
Joe and Nick, how bout it
folks, isn't that exciting?
(applause)
Gonna be a hot rip here, boys.